[Musique]
le climat change tout le monde voit
c'est clair on n'a pas besoin de faire
un doctorat pour ça mais ce que j'ai
appris il ya quelques minutes en
regardant j'étais en train de regarder
quand vous arriviez tous si vous êtes
tous des grands spécialistes du
changement climatique sans le savoir
j'ai regardé tout simplement les uns et
les autres se garer garer leur voiture
j'ai regardé par exemple que quand vous
essayez de garder vos véhicules
vous essayez de trouver un coin en tout
cas le coin où il ya le plus d'ombré et
malheureusement à un moment il ya plus
de place donc vous êtes obligé de vous
garer au soleil et joie que naquit sont
pas très content et je regarde de très
près il se gare au soleil il ferme la
ville mais juste un tout petit peu il
laisse un tout petit peu
pourquoi parce que vous êtes tous des
grands spécialistes experts du
changement climatique parce que vous
l'avez vécu vous savez que si vous garez
votre véhicule au soleil pendant un
certain temps quand vous arrivez et que
vous ouvrez la porte
il fait beaucoup plus chaud dans la
voiture course de la voiture d'un s'ils
voulaient laisser la voiture faire mais
assez longtemps avec les vitres fermées
les vitres ont explosé
tout simplement parce que les rayons du
soleil le soleil entre il fait chaud ça
chauffe
la température augmente et à un moment
ça saute et bien considérer que la
planète
c'est votre voiture c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer
tout simplement
c'est à dire que y'a comme avec le
véhicule
la chaleur cliente il ya des gaz qui
chauffe la planète
je vais prendre un autre exemple tout le
monde a fait la cuisine ou moins tout le
monde a regardé sa femme faire la
cuisine
je vois des hommes qui font très bien la
cuisine et vous savez que très
simplement
vous ouvrez le gaz mettez le feu
plus vous ouvrez le gaz plus accueilli
et quand vous ne faites pas attention
eh ben ça crame tous la même chose avec
le charbon c'est le même principe vous
mettez du charbon vous voulez augmenter
l'intensité la chaleur et ben vous
mettez encore plus de charbon et ça crie
plus vite
c'est exactement ce qui se passe pour
faire encore un peu plus simple
imaginez donc comme je le disais la
planète c'est l'équivalent d'un autre
marmite de notre véhicule donc imaginer
que il ya 196 pays au monde
on va faire des blocs on va dire la
chine par exemple arrivent elles à une
bonbonne de gaz de à peu près 30 kg les
etats-unis arrivent bonbonnes de gaz
15 kg les européens arrivent bonbonnes
de gaz après 10 kg l'afrique 54 pays 50
55 pays bonbonnes de gaz
3,3 kg tout le monde allume le gaz
l'afrique à 54 peut mettre son gaz à
fond ça pas beaucoup d'impact
la chine par contre énormément les états
unis énormément c'est pour ça que le
monde se retrouve à 197 pour demander
aux uns aux autres est ce que tu peux
baiser un petit peu baissé un peu ton
gaz parce que moi ça fait mal c'est ça
la différence
le changement climatique
c'est sérieux c'est peut-être le seul
problème en tant que continent qu'on n'a
pas réglé
enfin cela peut-être le seul problème
qu'en tant que continent nous n'avons
pas créé tout le monde le sait il ya des
autorités qui dans la salle les grands
défis pour notre continent
je pense que la lutte contre la pauvreté
sans net et les solutions existent le
dividende démographique exactement on
sait que c'est un défi mais qu'il faut
le régler voilà un problème qui compte
auxquels l'afrique est confrontée non
seulement qui n'a pas réglé mais qu'il
ne peut qu'il n'a pas causés mais qui ne
peut pas régler tout seul
vous êtes obligé de vous asseoir autour
d'une table pour au moins que le
problème en tout cas en terme de du
phénomène vous puissiez l'adresser
première premier problème
deuxième problème c'est un problème qui
coûtent excessivement cher
d'après le programme des nations unies
sur l'environnement
l'afrique a besoin aujourd'hui d'à peu
près 7 à 15 milliards de dollars pour
s'adapter aux impacts du changement
climatique
quand on parle d'un pacte pour faire
très simple de quoi est ce qu'il s'agit
l'augmentation de la température par
exemple induit une augmentation de
l'humidité
l'augmentation de l'humidité induit une
baisse des rendements agricoles
les précipitations en termes d'impact je
pense que tout le monde a compris qu'il
ya un problème soit les plus et plus
arrivent plus tôt soit elles arrivent
plus tard soit quand elles arrivent en
termes de volumes de précipitations
vous avez en deux jours trois jours tout
ce qui doit tomber en trois mois donc
même pour des zones qui ne connaissait
pas beaucoup de plus vous avez
aujourd'hui en termes de fréquence et
d'intensité
les sécheresses et des inondations nos
coûts très rapidement 7 15 milliards de
dollars aujourd'hui
2020 à peu près 35 milliards de dollars
2050 à peu près 50 milliards de dollars
pour l'afrique en termes de coûts
les économistes disent ça va nous coûter
à peu près 7% du pib pib pour faire
simple ça c'est des gros mots que les
économistes utilisent la richesse qu'on
produit quand on sait que la grande
majorité des pays africains ou même au
niveau mondial n'ont même pas une
croissance justement de la richesse de
5% par an ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il ya de fortes chances
que les gains que nous faisons en termes
de développement et bien une année
arrive une sécheresse et vous venez de
perdre 10 ans 15 ans j'ai une amie qui
est ambassadrice pour le climat dans une
île la barbade
ils viennent de connaître un ouragan le
plus important de leur histoire ils ont
perdu 50 % des infrastructures
économiques en 24 heures donc vous voyez
un peu et pour beaucoup se sont endettés
il va falloir il va falloir rembourser
tout ça donc non seulement c'est cher
mais c'est également un problème de
développement les impacts valentré dans
chacun de vos domaines en termes
d'agriculture les prix en termes
d'énergie pour des pays qui ne
produisent pas d'hydrocarbures
la facture pour justement non seulement
la subvention c'est à dire ce que l'état
mais pour que le prix ne soit pas
réfléter généralement vous avez ce
montant là est supérieur aux
contributions du gouvernement pour la
santé pour l'éducation
on paye du carburant on subventionne le
prix du carburant est ce qu'on met
dedans et et le plus triste c'est que
c'est dans des états où justement il
pourrait y avoir d'autres solutions
quand le maroc s'engage par exemple pour
augmenter la part des énergies
renouvelables jusqu'à 52% dans son mix
énergétique
ce n'est pas pour faire plaisir au
climat c'est parce que le ministre des
finances de ce pays c'est que ça lui
coûte très cher d'importer du carburant
et donc qu'il faut aller vers des
énergies propres
tout simplement parce qu'il y en a en
abondance c'est le nouveau câble etc
et c'est moins cher donc le problème est
sérieux ce n'est pas un problème
environnemental
c'est un problème de développement
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on fait les
japonais ont inventé ce terme s'adapter
innover ou mourir
la première des choses c'est comprendre
on ne peut pas régler un problème quand
on le comprend pas et là le premier
point c'est déjà comprendre le phénomène
que nous subissons et ça se fait juste à
travail à travers des données à travers
l'observation l'observation systématique
avoir des données comprendre quel va
être l'impact de ce phénomène dans un
secteur et sur un territoire donné
si vous êtes en plein milieu du désert
vous allez parement connaître une
accélération du processus de
désertification
si vous avez un cours d'eau le sable
valentré beaucoup plus dans vos cours
d'eau si vous êtes si vous vivez sur la
côte
par exemple vous allez avoir
l'accélération de l'érosion côtière
si vous avez construit des routes sur la
cote si vous avez construit des
infrastructures
il ya des risques que ces
infrastructures disparaissent si vous
êtes un pays et que le tourisme vous
tente
on a eu des exemples assez intéressant
en afrique où beaucoup avaient un
potentiel touristique voulait utiliser
leur voulait notamment avoir des plages
50 10 ans ya plus de plage
donc si vous voulez que les touristes
viennent pour être sur la plage et que
dans dix ans il n'y a plus de plage vous
voyez que ce n'est pas seulement un
problème du ministre de la ville
mais ça va être un problème un peu pour
pour pour un peu tout le monde donc le
premier point comprendre le phénomène
observé le phénomène et pouvoir le
comprendre au niveau le plus local parce
que les réponses au niveau local donc ça
c'est la première solution
les pays qui se bat qui réussissent le
mieux ont des systèmes d'observation
très poussées et ils peuvent même
quantifier pas me dire voilà en termes
de baisse du rendement agricole sa
pourrait nous coûter tant à l'horizon x
en termes de perte du cheptel
ça pourrait nous coûter tant à l'horizon
x en termes d'énergie nous dépensons à
peu près 100 150 millions de dollars par
an pour subventionner les hydrocarbures
voilà ce que ça nous coûte ensuite il
vous faut des politiques et des
programmes
il vous faut renforcer les capacités de
vos institutions à pouvoir intégrer cela
dans les différents plans
ensuite il ya des secteurs et tous les
secteurs ici sont concernés je vois
beaucoup de personnes du secteur privé
le secteur privé très concernés le
premier domaine bien sûr c'est celui des
énergies renouvelables même dans
l'agriculture l'irrigation la petite
irrigation augmente vos rendements vous
êtes moins vulnérable aux chocs
climatiques les banques beaucoup
d'instruments financiers existent
aujourd'hui pour couvert face pouvoir
faire face à ces risques en terme
d'instruments de couverture risque
climatique en termes d'obligations
vertes et le secteur des transports
nous avons aujourd'hui dans la plupart
des villes africaines un niveau de
pollution atmosphérique est supérieur à
beijing qui est supérieur en inde
quand il existe des véhicules
électriques des motos électriques et
donc les solutions existent par secteurs
et les solutions existent par instrument
qu'est ce que fait l'afrique elle
s'organise l'afrique s'organise le mali
fait partie de l'afrique et joue un rôle
important
le climat est peut-être la seule
question qui est traitée à trois niveaux
qui est arrêté au niveau des experts
quand les experts arrivent en bout de
chaîne et passe le dossier au ministre
quand les ministres arrivent en bout de
chaîne il passe le dossier aux chefs
d'état donc il ya un comité permanent
des chefs d'état africains qui regarde
les solutions qu'ils le gardent les
propositions des négociateurs afrique en
plus de cela puisque c'est un problème
qui est local est spécifique
il existe aujourd'hui des initiatives
pour justement valoriser les
opportunités en termes d'énergies
renouvelables en termes d'adaptation du
secteur du secteur agricole en termes de
développement d'instruments financiers
pour faire face à tout cela et donc mon
petit point tout simplement
c'était cela c'est de vous dire que face
à tous les défis que nous avons et jesse
elle sert que l'afrique à des défis
l'avait dit pauvreté démographie
migration celui là beaucoup plus vicieux
que les autres c'est une tendance lourde
il va rester et il faudra le traité
parce que nous n'arriverons pas où nous
allons beaucoup de mal à atteindre les
objectifs tant que celui là on le traite
pas mais comme vous le savez tous les
défis sont faits pour être relevés
les solutions existent les innovations
sont là donc en même temps c'est une
chance extraordinaire parce que un bond
qualitatif peut être fait on prend
souvent le cas de la téléphonie où
beaucoup de pays africains sont passés
directement n'ont même pas connu le
téléphone sans fil pour aller enfin le
téléphone filaire pour aller sur le
téléphone sans fil donc il ya des bonds
technologiques qu'on peut faire et
beaucoup de pays africains aujourd'hui
en terme de téléphonie sont au point à
la pointe de la technologie est la même
chose se passe pour l'agriculture pour
le transport pour les énergies donc je
vous invite tous à développer notre
potentiel vous remercie
[Applaudissements]